good morning
um i hope the weather is nice where you
are i'm currently admiring the um
gently wet british weather out of my
window
it's a good reminder to remain indoors
the image that you are seeing
um somehow vaguely fits with this idea
of paradigms lost
this is a picture i took last year in
pripyat in the
chernobyl uh exclusion zone in ukraine
and
yes you can visit a radioactive uh world
disaster site and buy mugs
so this is a genuine genuine sample
there the coffee however is not
radioactive
that's my responsibility so what are we
going to talk about
we're going to talk about a bunch of
stuff here um we're going to talk
about paradigms lost paradigms regained
um programming with objects and
functions and more
i want to focus on a number of different
aspects here
um the challenge for me is that i
actually
run this as a one day kind of seminar
um and so i did the major mistake of
trying to condense that
that was my first draft i threw that one
away because it was you can't take one
day and turn it into
one hour with any success so i inverted
the whole thing i've turned the whole
thing inside out and basically said
right
let's start from scratch we'll take a
different line through this
so a little bit about me um my name's
kevin henny
i i don't actually have an app in front
of my name but my name is sufficiently
unique that
i can get away with it i've written
stuff on
patterns and i've um have an interest in
uh architecture um
in the software world very much really
my interest in patterns is how do people
think
how do people organize things um a lot
of people think of patterns as just a
catalog of interesting ideas and it's
like that's not really it
there's something much deeper there is a
thinking model um
that is uh profound and we will actually
see relates to paradigms very strongly
um i'm also interested very much in the
detail of code and practices so
10 years ago um i published this book uh
edited this book kind of a crowdsourced
open source book 97 things every
programmer should know
uh most recently um myself and trisha g
um published 97 things every java
programmer should know
a very different focus in that sense
kind of like 10 years on
a specific language takes everything in
a very different direction
and that was fun it's nice to do
something during lockdown um
but that's not why we're here let's talk
about this
paradigms the p word in fact it did
actually get
known uh uh one place i worked in the
early 90s as the p word because paradigm
was being mentioned so often because
people were starting to talk about
let's move to objects and up to that
point we've been doing a lot of
procedural programming
and people talk to occasionally about
modularity proceduralism
functional programming was an academic
dream occasionally logic programming
whenever you brought that up somebody
would say oh yeah i did prologue at
university
and that would be it that would be the
end of the pro that would be the end of
the logic programming conversation
um but most code was being written
at that point in c variants of pascal
fortran cover all this kind of stuff you
know
variations of basic they were never
actually a procedural paradigm but they
were
variations of it but at this time people
talking objects late 80s early 90s this
was when it was coming in
and the word paradigm started raising
its head now what is interesting is we
actually have we can actually
get a point of origin for the use of the
word paradigm
um in in programming uh it's this guy
robert floyd um uh he was involved in a
lot of um
thinking in the 60s in particular on uh
formalisms
if you're familiar with tony hawe's
ideas in fact formal methods owes this
man of great debt
um tony hall's ideas of like a
precondition
an action and a post condition for
reasoning about code which we these
these days we see reflected in uh
behavior driven development
given when then it's exactly the same
three aspects
uh that and tony hawk is quite
acknowledges this very very clearly and
explicitly and openly that's
actually based on robert floyd's work um
so he received the turing award
in 1979 um
and he talked about the paradigms of
programming and he
adopted the term paradigms based on um
the popularity in the 60s of uh thomas
coon's um
structure actually structured scientific
revolutions if i had thought about this
i would go and grab my copy because
one of the great things about being at
home let's look at the positive side is
that i can grab
books that i have and show them to you
um but yeah that one's kind of in the
other room
what is interesting is before 1979
people didn't talk about paradigms 1979
they started using the p
word um you can see this in the 1978 um
turing award winner john backus who
spoke about functional programming his
turing award paper and speech
he only talks about the functional style
one year later everybody's using the
paradigm word
so paradigm let's talk about the word
paradigm oh good grief i mean
you know as if you didn't already have
enough trouble with english spelling
here is a word that has a silent g but
only sometimes
because it's paradigm but when we are
talking about paradigms or relating
something we may say that something is
paradigmatic suddenly the g rears its
ugly head
um for that we totally blame english
but if we look at the origin of the word
we see down
left-hand side we can see oh okay it's
greek
uh paradigma is ultimately where it
comes from
um it means a pattern it means an
example pattern that word
um an example something to follow
an archetype it's very interesting but
we think we understand what we're
talking about when we say paradigms when
you drop that into a conversation with
developers
often people talk as if they are
pursuing a single
paradigm which one is better the one
you know it's neo it's the matrix we are
after the one
actually robert floyd's thesis the whole
point of what he was trying to talk
about
this is i believe that the current state
of the art of computer programming
reflects inadequacies in our stocker
paradigms
in our knowledge of existing paradigms
in the way we teach programming
paradigms
and in the way our programming languages
support fail to support the paradigms of
their user communities
he's talking about this as a plural he
doesn't want the one true paradigm he
says
you have different problems you need
different shapes of solution and these
will
all be the same shape there is no the
one
and so what is interesting there is
exactly what he said 40 years ago i
would like to repeat here
uh the moment we we find people pursuing
or
obsessed by the one paradigm yet when we
look more closely at our languages
we find that most of the languages that
are in current use do not support
a paradigm there are blender paradigms
paradigms
do not have these norms they don't have
boundaries you know you are suddenly
leaving the procedural quadrant and now
entering the functional sector it's not
like that you know you you're checking
your state mutability at the boundary
and that's it there's a hard distinction
and you move from object
into functional as if there was no
distinction and
in fact i've heard some people say oh
there are only two or three paradigms
it's like i've got really bad news for
you
here's the paradigm map as of 2005
according to peter van roy
and i would actually highlight that he's
missed out a whole bunch
i can think of straight there but this
is a good analysis and he's broken it
down along a number of axes
uh with separations cheering
completeness uh not um how we relate to
state
and he's banded things and showed
relationships this so this is a
so what we're saying here is this is a
good first stretch at a paradigm map
but actually we can see there are things
missing we have more examples and
uh that we can throw in more things that
are in between in spaces as it were
rather than sitting comfortably inside
boxes
so one of my favorite quotes emil
augusta
nothing is more dangerous than an idea
when you have only one idea
i i love using this quote because it's
always a reminder when we come to design
thinking
um programming style or even life
that we tend to get fixated we get
locked into one thing the whole idea is
challenge yourself
and we can actually generalize this in
software nothing is more dangerous than
an ide when you have only one ide
um and we also see this in particular
nothing is more dangerous than our when
you have only one object
and for many people it's just like oh
object orientation you mean the
singleton
pattern it's just like no no we
absolutely do not mean the signal to
pattern
um you know that's a failure mode that's
that's not the bit we're putting forward
and saying please follow this this is
good
um we're saying this is the bit you
don't want to do
but there is an important point here
that we often pursue paradigms not
because of the problems which are solved
not
always because of the nature of our
languages but sometimes we want
something better
we become uncomfortable a paradigm has
become let me put it this way a lot of
what people are doing
and calling object orientation it's not
what i was taught
it's not it was not the promise um but
that happens for every paradigm
um i see a number of well-meaning but
very naive people jumping onto
you know having dealt with functional
programming for quite a long time
i i love the way people go like oh yeah
functional program is the answer because
oh is all singletons and managers and
it's like no really that wasn't the idea
um what does the enterprisation of
functional programming look like
the enterprisation of functional
programming is already happening we see
functions called function we see people
using hybrid languages
and saying i've got this really big big
super long function or method
or whatever and it's just like it
because i'm doing functional it's like
honestly some data abstraction would
really help you at this point
and we know what the failure mode of
functional programming is what that
looks like
the failure mode of object orientation
is
managerialism the failure mode of
functional programming is called
procedural programming
in other words oh we have pragmatic side
effects you know some when people use
the word pragmatic it normally means not
so when people do pragmatic agile it's
not agile
you know when people do pragmatic tdd
it's not tdd when people are doing
pragmatic functional programming
it's not functional programming they
have pragmatic side effects and
pragmatic others so
we're already seeing this in some effect
that's not to dis fp at all fp is really
quite
uh significant in the landscape but it's
our hopes that are being
surprised by uh we're being surprised so
what i need is one idea that i'm going
to run through all of this
so we're going to talk about stacks so
this is the seven magic mountains
outside las vegas
um back in a world where we used to be
able to travel um yeah i was in las
vegas last year
with the family and this was
much more interesting than the fake
eiffel tower there stacks are very
common ideas we find them there's a
stack of books that's all about objects
psychotherapists are utterly obsessed
with the concepts of objects
um we also find the term uh we talk
about full stack developer
stacks are obsessed people are obsessed
in fact if you want the best kind of
full stack developer you need them to be
passionate as well
um although i find that uh when i look
at
um what people mean by actually full
stack development
it's it's kind of small their universe
is apparently the full stack is front
end and back end
um my background is that i used to work
in infrastructure
systems programming and middleware and
for me what most people call full stack
development is somewhere out there
my bit of the stack is completely
neglected and the other area i guess i'm
interested in is the um
the other aspect how do we do products
what is the effect on society it turns
out the stack is surprisingly deep
and what we call full stack is a tiny
squinchy bit in the middle
but that's not the stack we're going to
talk about i'm going to talk about data
abstraction
this is my perfect excuse to use upside
down a's and back to front e's in a talk
to commercial programmers there exists a
type t
this is generic such that for all stacks
and then i offer you a cartesian product
with a series of
um functional mappings um
uh some of which are partial um so
popping a stack does not always yield a
stack it's sometimes
it's not an allowed operation popping an
empty stack so that's that's
getting the top of the stack is not
always legal because it doesn't have a
top
the way that we frame the types here
we're going to say that's not always
true
so what we're talking about here is
abstract data types adt's so let's start
there
adts abstract datasets we have um
there this is an idea from the early 70s
specifically this is barbara liskoff
while we're talking about cheering award
winners she was the winner i think in
2008 2009 i could be off by one
um her work in programming language
design
was really quite significant quite
important
if you are using a language that has an
exception handling mechanism that looks
roughly like try catch
try except or whatever that comes down
to the language
work that she did in the 1970s the clu
clue language
but she is one of the key people
involved in this whole
idea of adt's this is from her 1974
paper
programming with abstract data types now
what's interesting here she says
an abstract data type defines a class of
abstract objects
which is completely characterized by the
operations available on those objects
a program is concerned only with the
behavior of which that object exhibits
but
not any details of how that behavior is
achieved by means of an implementation
a lot of people going like oh okay yeah
cool right yeah we do this all the time
you know this is this is classes
okay so if i throw this one at you in c
sharp
then i've got some private
implementation which as uh
uh liskoff says we're not interested in
characterized completely by its public
operations its public aspect is push pop
depth and top let's keep it really
simple
and i'm going to make pop a pure pop
actually there are reasons i might come
to you later why
why i've done it this way um but i'm
going to keep it really really simple
you want to find out
the value that you're about to pop ask
for the top that's it and i can
implement it i can implement it in c
sharp using the standard.net generic
collection list which is
basically a resizable array vector in
other languages arraylist and others
it's uh so it's based on contiguous
memory
and i can push and pop freely i've got
my exception behavior nicely
characterized there
a number of forwarding operations so
this is stack implemented as a wrapper
and i've chosen a particular sensibility
here
i have decided that the head of the
stack will be
the zeroth element of the list and if
you look through there you will see that
there there it is at zero
insert zero that's my push so we've got
a really simple uh there and pop remove
at zero
but i could equally well do it the other
way around and actually it's
marginally more efficient um to do it
the other way around
that push appends at the back that's
what ad does by default but it means
that i remove
from there so i count backwards
effectively
or i could use a linked list and i could
take things from the la
i could treat the top as the last
element or i could treat it as the first
element now notice
all of these variations have been done
without any um without any appeal
to a difference in terms of this
perceived semantics
but this is not what barbara liskoff was
talking about
in many of our minds when we read a lot
of stuff on adts particularly if you
come through the object route and that's
been your main exposure
you will think oh yeah yeah that's what
i'm doing and it kind of is but it's not
the whole story
so um this book uh theory of objects
um i'm gonna i'd love to say i've read
it i read the first section i think
there are five or six sections
i've read the first section the first
section is in english the remaining five
sections are in sigma calculus
and if you are struggling at any point
to
sleep at night i strongly recommend some
of those sections
um i yeah yeah not for me there are
people out there who have
far better appreciation uh of reading
formalisms but the first section is goal
absolutely really good clarifications
this book is published in 95.
and the point that a body and cardelli
make they say
object to origin programming does not
have an exclusive claim to all these
good properties those properties of data
abstraction and so on
systems may be modeled by other
paradigms the resilience that we've just
been describing
can be achieved just as well by
organizing programs around abstract data
types treat it as a separate concept the
whole private public keep your data
private type thing
is not unique to object orientation but
for many people particularly when they
come from a regular procedural
background
whether it's from scripting or from c
when they
see objects that's their big
that's their big enlightenment it's the
encapsulation that's
that's the thing they associate
primarily in their mind they say that
paradigm is about
that actually it's not there's actually
a bunch of paradigms that all share this
um so as uh uh cardelli say
organizing around abstract data types
independently of taxonomies what they're
referring to here is class hierarchies
and type hierarchies
in fact data abstraction alone is
sometimes taken as the essence of object
orientation so this is
like category substitution that we do
but i've been mentioning c um so let's
talk c
um you can do adt programming in c in
fact that's where i started doing adt
programming although
when i did it i thought i was doing a
kind of like bankrupt version of
objects actually i was doing adt
programming i feel much better about it
historically
um i can forward declare um i can fully
declare a structure i can
uh i don't have to use it i'm going to
use a name convenience
uh typedef and put stack and it's just
gonna be a stack
so i've now forward declared it it's
incomplete
um and but i can still define operations
on it
i can still declare go ahead and say i
can have a new thing i can get rid of it
i can do push pop i can find the depth
and i can ask for the top so i'm going
to bind the type much more specifically
here rather there's no concept of
genericity
and i really wasn't in the mood to use
void pointers this morning
um you know honestly it's towards the
end of the week why would i give myself
that pain so i'm going to just make it
very specific
um and make it about strings
so we can i can do this um in c
it's not necessarily a common style in c
um but i know that whenever i've
encouraged people to do this there have
been benefits and when i did it
i found huge benefits in separation in
terms of reasoning but also build times
and other aspects
but it is a capability c supports even
though it doesn't present itself as
a an adt language it is a capability of
support but it's not its principal
home territory if you like there are
languages
for which this is a a a prime um
uh uh aspect so this is modular two
um again if i thought about this my
modular two book i can actually see off
to one side
um uh what i've done there is i've
i've created an opaque type type stack
is
offered there but it's not defined um
it's kept
set that definition is kept separate i
can create it delete it push pot depth
top all of these usual things
but modular two has something else this
is the idea that we don't generally end
up with
languages that are unique um uh have
support only a single paradigm they
normally bring in something else
as the name modular two suggests it's
all about the modules
modular programming if you like
modularity is partly orthogonal to how
we organize
our data types and uh our procedural
aspects of code
it's it's an organizing principle we
find in languages
as different as python and haskell and
haskell we regard very much
as the epitome of functional programming
thinking and python
although it is an object-oriented
language its default mode of usage
is a kind of a light procedure with
hints and a light sprinkling of
functional
and it supports a modular concept now i
can't
actually strictly speaking do full
modular programming in something like c
or c plus plus c plus plus 20 has
modules but
they're kind of different and i'm not
going to get into that
um the modular programming idea that i
deal with headers and so on in
languages like c the module does not
have identity the key
idea that we get with python and with
modular 2 and languages like that going
back to ada
and so on is that these languages the
module has identity you can name it
you import things from it you have you
don't just have concepts of public and
private but you have a namespace concept
built
into the structural unit it's part of
the language
now that of course itself is not a new
idea many people will date modular
thinking to the 1970s and i know we take
a way wayback machine all the way to the
1960s
we go back to the nato software
engineering conference
in garmish in 1968. actually there was
an awful lot said about this
um to find a subset of the system which
is small enough to bring to an
operational state
this strategy requires the system be
designed in modules which can be
realized tested and modified
independently
what is important here is that
modularity was being proposed
and discussed and reasoned about as you
can tell from the phrasing
it was being offered as a um
a way of thinking about uh a
methodological approach
as you can see he offers a recipe to
find a subset of the system this
strategy he's talking about a way of
development
with respect to a team and so on so in
other words modularity fulfills a
human need in that sense the reason many
people associate
modularity with the 1970s is because of
david parnass
who basically came up with a much
clearer view
of and how should we do our modules if
you like modularity was an idea from the
late 60s people started reasoning about
breaking their code into chunks and
chunks that were not simply subroutines
and functions
but chunks that cohered together but
there was discussion about and why do we
make
them modules and so parnis's 1972 paper
on criteria to be used in decomposing
systems into modules we propose
that one begins with a list of difficult
design decisions or design decisions
which
are likely to change each module is then
designed to hide such a decision from
the others wait a minute ah
i see like changing the implementation
like i just did with the stack i've got
it so
notice here that we've already noticed
that
that we're able to blend there's a
little soft boundary between some of
these
um some of these paradigms and some of
these live together
but the ideas are mature but these days
we often look at something and go
got it you mean objects it's like well
not just objects there are
other aspects data abstraction is
something you can do in multiple
languages
um modularity without data abstraction
is something we can do in multiple
languages
without needing to tie ourselves to a
specific paradigm
but back to this idea of hiding
decisions from other people well i did
it with c
sharp i want to show you if i take this
as
c i can go and add a little bit of extra
dressing around it
so that it will also compile i've been
very careful that this is actually
um c and c plus plus yeah
c plus plus c was originally kind of
like a
nc c89 or iso c90
was there was a strict subset
relationship and that was bianna
strausstrap's intention
but with a few of the options taken out
but the subset relationship was really
strong
as each of those languages has evolved
c99 c11 c17
c plus 98 11 14 17 20 keep counting
they've diverged there are the common
subset is
proportionately smaller but what i've
offered you on screen here is
is uh in that subset and i can
elaborate this in a dot c file i can
offer you a full definition of what do i
mean by stract
by stack i've got a struct here and i've
got the
the joy of pointers to pointers and i've
got information there and everything's
doing what it should do
um but i can also implement it in c plus
plus
and link that in and the point there is
that this is a link time concept and
that was actually something that you
found in a lot of the
early modular thinking and early adt
thinking the idea was not to deal with
um substitutable types with respect to
an interface at runtime the idea was
very much a compile time or link
time change whereas in many of the
languages we deal with with objects if
you change the private section
both that sets off a ripple in your
build the idea is that if you are
working in a language that truly
supports modules and abstract data types
then if you change the implementation
it does not trigger a huge build it is
merely
it's a recombination of that module and
everything else just links in
and if you're working in a dynamic
environment with dlls or shared objects
that just comes in so in other words
there's no difference it's a minimal
change paradigm
that is not true of many object systems
that we have now so there is
again there are other aspects that come
out of that
but since we're time travelling um let's
go back to
the early 70s um uh structured
programming
um this was the kind of prevailing uh as
it were
organizational model or good practice
procedural programming uh the people
were talking about
um and this book i said early 70s but
strictly speaking it
it involves a collection of essays from
uli johann dar
etzke dijkstra and tony hall from kind
of late 60s onwards it's not really
written as a
single book it's really actually a set
of essays authored or co-authored by
each of these
individuals but they make a really
important point about
one of the most key ideas we can
actually say within procedural
programming there is a sub paradigm that
we can call
block structured programming not every
um
language that is procedural has block
structure
c and c plus plus are of that heritage
basically anything with curly brackets
is of that heritage anything with begin
and end is of their heritage
not everything is though um you know the
languages of that time things like
fortran
don't follow that uh we also see that in
mod that's not just but that's not just
an old thing language is like python
they're not actually strictly streaking
block structure they don't have the
concept of block scope
although they allow nested procedures
and there is clearly a strong
strong sense of indentation um the
concept of the block does not strictly
exist
and so yeah that's not necessarily a
disadvantage uh you have languages that
pretend to be block structured
um a classic javascript as an example it
has blocks but it totally disrespects
what they mean
modern javascript is a little a little
tighter on this but still allows you
that
old-school fluidity but the observation
in hierarchical programmed
uh program structures at the darling
hall row
they made this observation one of those
powerful mechanisms for program
structuring
is the block and procedure concept that
idea of being able to and this is
something that many languages lost so c
lost the block and procedure concept it
kept the block but it did not allow you
to embed procedures within the block
that was something that was lost
um pascal
kept the nested procedures but did not
allow you to nest
uh data within blocks so they each kind
of took a different path but let's go
all the way back i'm basically going to
look here old school begin end
this is um an algol 60 derivative
um so algorithmic language 60 algal 60.
really this is the language that gave us
bnf um
and it is the language that really
launched block structure obviously many
languages later decided that begin and
end that's way too much typing we're
going to put curly brackets or round
brackets or
some variation of brackets in that place
um
this is a slight extension to it i'm
going to take the concept of a book
we'll discover what a book is in a
moment
uh or rather what it could be um i'm
going to make it
uh i have an array of reference to books
and the number of
books is one to some kind of capacity
and um
we're going to have an integer count
that we've got there so
just as a point of history algol is the
language that put
the type name at the front and then the
variable name and this is
what c picked up on
so this is the language to blame for
that practice um
uh and uh i can go ahead i can
initialize count to zero
um but i can also nest procedures within
this
so the point is that blocks are
recursive within a block you can contain
all of the ingredients of a program
including more procedures
a procedure for push and pop and is
empty as full
depth and so on i have to put in these
full because it's a bounded we are
limited we can't we don't have resizable
arrays in this era it's limited to
whatever capacity it's
but what is interesting about this is
that i've just kind of told you
something that you probably already know
but you're perhaps translating it into
curly brackets or going oh i can't do
that
in in the language that i'm using
because i'm not allowed to nest
procedures but you know maybe i could do
something like it
we have seen some languages reclaim the
idea of nested procedures
i've noticed c sharp did that while back
um
and you kind of fake it in c plus plus
with kind of like
you know local classes and lambdas and
stuff but it's still not first class in
that sense
but languages like python never gave it
up but there's some really interesting
ideas
what if we go the next step because
the observation was made in this section
called the hierarchical program
structures
so what we've discovered is that a
process a block
can hold behavior and it can hold data
and it can hold code that runs that's a
really interesting idea andrew we can do
anything with that
a procedure which is capable of giving
rise to block into instances which
survive its call will be known as a
class
and the instances will be known as
objects of that class
it turns out that object orientation
grew out of block structure
what they are describing johann dahl is
one of the co-inventors with kristen
negard
of um and for all the norwegians out
there i'm really sorry i'm not
pronouncing it right
but you know um uh it's the best i can
do today
um uh similar 67
the language that we're dealing with
here is actually similar 67
their ideas come from a previous
language similar one which was 1965
they took algol 60 and extended it they
wanted to
deal with simulations and they found
that procedures were the wrong
ingredient the algorithmic stuff
they didn't want to think about
simulations in terms of algorithms they
wanted to think about simulations in
terms of things
and classes of things well let's change
the word thing to object that sounds a
little more technical
um and they they didn't add they didn't
bolt something onto the language they
took a thing that was already there
if i've got a block normally what
happens in a block structured piece of
code the way you have
instinctively thought about it is i
enter at the beginning of the block
variables happen if i've got procedures
procedures get defined
and then the code happens yeah we can
mix the order of these up depending on
the language
but we're allowed to there and then when
we leave the block
that is a stack frame it pops it
disappears we're done
but what if it didn't what if the block
instance this unity of data
and action survived and you could give
it identity and point to it and pass it
around hey here's the thing it's got
stuff in it and it can do stuff
could that give rise to a new paradigm
well yeah actually it turns out it does
so we take the code that i had before
and i just add the class keyword in
front and
there's no concept of constructor here
um
the original idea which is actually
somewhat simpler i have to admit that
many of the things that we find in in
our
current languages um is this idea of
i initialize a class as if a function i
pass something in that data is always
available it's immediately part of the
state
and here is what would historically be
called constructor code
that runs at the end once we've reached
the end of this block we now have a
surviving block instance that we can now
refer to
and we can pass it around so it's a
persistent block
not a block that evaporates when you
leave this is a really profound idea and
then we get this idea a call of a class
generates a new object to that class
boom object orientation is a version
is object rotation and proceduralism
have a really close relationship
but there's something else going on here
so you might think well hang on
that that's interesting because what
you're describing there
kathleen is um a closure
you have got something that captures its
surrounding context
you know that's interesting because i'm
going to use i'm going to use
um javascript because hey why the hell
not um
because javascript actually has inside
it it actually has a really elegant
object model
i mean it has half a dozen object models
just in case you don't like the really
elegant one
um but the really elegant one doesn't
use the word class and it's not based on
function prototypes
a function prototype model really simple
idea i'm going to use lambdas and this
idea of lambdas and closures is a really
intimate one but many people think oh
lambdas you must be doing functional
programming uh lambdas aren't unique to
functional programming lambdas are
unique to programming
you'll actually find lambdas and the
concept specifically
applied of closures is fundamental to
many paradigms it's not
uh it's not distinct to functional
programming
indeed there are many functional
programs programmers that don't actually
do lambdas very
either at all or very well because the
principle unit of composition is the
function it's not necessarily the
freestanding function it is the function
clearly for many people they think again
this is one of those ones that
just like i mistakenly and many others
have mistaken the concept of data
abstraction has been unique to objects
for the first time you encounter you go
hey this is object orientation it might
well be abstract data types
it might be one of the other modular
approaches the same thing i noticed a
lot among a lot of programmers because
many of the
programming languages these days have
been saying hey guess what we've added
lambdas
so c plus plus added lambda is in 2011
java added it in 2014
and everyone's been adding them
javascript's and they're going like
please i've been doing this since the
20th century it's the mid-1990s
it had lambdas in there it might not
have had the arrow notation but it had
um landers that was part of the
inspiration uh
for it but that idea is for many people
to go oh i'm now doing fictional program
no you're not you're just programming
with lenders and functional programming
is
a lot more than lambdas um some of these
languages that are acquiring landers
that you can be a little more functional
in them but you're not doing necessarily
doing functional programming
if you're a java programmer that is a
language that will never be functional
um because you can't define a function a
freestanding function in it until you
can
we can't consider it functional um but
you can do
lambda-y things and more functional
things that's certainly true but there's
a purity here that allows us to get
inside
the essence of the object model so we've
understood the object model from
proceduralism
let's understand where it comes from
here what i've got is i've got
so i'm going to do everything with
lambdas i'm going to have a function
called new stack
or rather i'm going to have a name that
i'm going to bind to a
lambda but when executed this is a block
there is state in this block it's a list
called items
that and then i'm going to return a
cartesian product or
object or dictionary however you want to
look at it um and each this contains
lambdas that refer to this private state
this is the ultimate in private
it's not a keyword that says private
that i can inspect
or hack using reflection it is the
ultimate primary this is a local
variable
there is no way from the outside to get
into it
what i get what i'm offering the outside
world and this actually starts taking us
into territory that
um for those of you who are old enough
to show the scars
uh looks more like microsoft con than
anything which is actually bizarre
enough a pure object model
um i'm going to offer you an interface
here's a set of here's a set of
functions well here's a set of names
that bind to lambdas that then further
refer to private state
you don't get to look at that state
there's no types here
i'll come back to types later but it is
a very pure object model it's purely
it's purely based on name that the data
is fully abstracted
i can switch my implementation round
here i'm taking the
the the head of the stack is at zero and
here it's back to front
so there's this really interesting idea
about this unity of ideas
which is observed by um william cook
um uh in a paper in 2009 where he
revisited a paper uh from 1984 by
cardellian wagner and that's the same
cardelli
um as a bardi and cardelli who wrote a
theory of objects
um and uh william cook
wrote this paper on understanding data
abstraction revisited there's a bunch of
interesting stuff there he gave a talk
on it as well
but he makes this uh wonderful
observation lambda calculus was the
first object-oriented language
um so it's kind of like whoa okay so
um a lot of people think oh yeah my
language has just got lambdas 21st
century
javascript is feeling a little bit smug
because it got it got its lambdas
um in 1995 lisp is feeling even even
more smug because in 1960 the first
implementation of this
that had lambdas but actually landers
that's the work
of alonzo church that dates back to 1932
and so basically if you've been getting
excited about lambdas
welcome to the 1930s programming like
it's um the first half of the last
century
um this is the the original paper uh the
explored this idea he did not create
lambdas because he cared about
programming programming was not a thing
he cared about it because he was trying
to explore
certain concepts in mathematics the
1930s were a very challenging time well
for the world but also for mathematics
um kurt gerdel in 1930 had just
published his incompleteness
theorems which kind of messed up
everybody's idea that math is complete
and elegant consistent
um and so there were a whole lot of
things that came out of that including
one that's probably more applicable to
us the halting problem as well as some
other ideas that came out of that
types type theory um but
he was exploring this so he created a
simple formalism um
and uh the better known paper is the
1936 paper
um and so i i will claim to have read
the words on these but not necessarily
fully understand uh
fully understanding all of the
consequences i'm not a mathematician by
training
um i used to deal with the real world
physics um and then i decided to escape
the real world and go into software
um so i've carefully avoided uh having
to know this stuff
mostly but we can create an abbreviation
i'm going to create a stack using pure
land capitalist
i'm going to equate the name new with
a a lambda taking two parameters that
yields a second one that's an arbitrary
decision i could do it any way i wanted
but that is my decision to create a new
stack
push is a little more fun we're going to
take
three elements one which is going to be
stack one which is going to be the new
element and we're going to bind them
together this is actually a form of data
abstraction we're going to
um it turns out that lambdas are all
about doing stuff
there's no such thing as typed lambda in
the original model
there's only lambdas so we can do this
and i can create a formalism for pop
and i can create a formalism for top
this is all good fun
i'm not going to linger on this i have a
different talk where i talk about
actually lambda calculus and how it
surprises us
um that uh where i explore this in more
detail but there you go that's
that's a lambda version of stack if you
want the purest version
uh that you could possibly get let's
pick up another aspect of
um this stuff object orientation
concatenation now you might not be
familiar with the term
but that's what we call inheritance or
derivation concatenation is an operation
defined between two classes a and b
or a class a and a block c what's really
interesting is the purity of similar
is it allows you to basically say well
it's all blocked
i can now actually have a block inherit
from a class
or as it were extend or concatenate a
class
and i can have blocks it's a very cool
kind of relationship
so what is a concatenation um it
consists in merging of the attributes of
both components
the base and the derived and the
composition of their actions
okay that's kind of extending and
overriding we can actually do that with
our nice little faked object model again
we don't actually need classes this is a
purely object-based model
i can define the concept of stackable
okay i'm going to define it by
capability and mix it i'm going to say a
stackable
is an opera is basically i take a base
and um i take whatever base class we
want and what i'm going to do is i
am going to add some operations to that
and some state and that's what the
assign operation here does
and so to get the stack that i had
before i can simply say
a new stack is now equivalent to a
stackable against an empty set of
operations an empty object
okay take an empty take an empty object
and now add stackability capability to
it i'm also going to add another
capability
clearable the thing that is clearable
when you call clear on it
empties out so now i've decided my new
stack is a clearable
stackable concept so i'm doing
composition here in fact
yeah function composition so
here we have some functional looking
code so i've just defined inheritance in
terms of what many people think of as
being
a functional programming concept
reduction or folding
we've got that i'm using function
composition to define
data abstraction and composition there's
a kind of unity here that's
quite intriguing it also makes us think
how do we use this mechanism because
this is the people think people got it
very excited
incorrectly reuse i can reuse everything
by inheriting um there are whole books
dedicated to this um
virtual miners object oriented software
construction a book of 30 years ago
people keep referring to this book but
very few people have
actually read it and because i was
running a workshop just beforehand
where i corrected somebody on their
incorrect use of
the open closed principle um so if you
are familiar with the open close
principle
um that is popularized by robert martin
wrote
that's wrong robert martin did not
correctly read the book he borrowed it
from
this is the original source
object-oriented software construction by
bertrand
in that you discover what it really is
um it's not at all what robert martin
thinks so if you think you're using the
open close principle in your code
have a chat with me afterwards it's all
based on a big misunderstanding but he
seems to have made a
certain profit out of it so he's not
going to change his understand but open
close principle is not what people think
it is
um also virtual meyer's advice was
pretty much inherit from everything
multiple inheritance is good
let us inherit from everything we want
to reuse this is terrible
and we already knew this was a bad idea
um
back in 1972 because we see here that
um darl and hall were very clear concept
hierarchies
the construction principle involved for
using concatenation
is best called abstraction we
concentrate on features common to many
phenomena we abstract away features too
far removed from the conceptual level at
which we are working
this is 72 we also have a much better
formalism
this one um is more it's not always what
correctly understood but it is
better understood um same barbara
liskoff this golf substitution principle
this is her 1987 paper
a type hierarchy is composed of subtypes
and super types
many people have taken this to be the
organizing discipline for a good class
hierarchy in object orientation
but she's actually not really talking
about objects in that sense or classes
she is talking about types
the intuitive idea of a subtype is one
of whose uh one whose objects provide
all the behavior of objects of another
type
super type plus something extra what is
wanted here is something like the
following substitution property
and honestly if you've just been eating
carbs for lunch you're going to fall
asleep in the next sentence
if for each object one of type s there
is an object o2 of type t
such that four programs p defined in
terms of t the behavior of p is
unchanged when o one is substitute for o
two then s is a subset of t it's like oh
man
okay i can actually the great thing
about
the list of substitution principle the
term lsp was coined by jim caplin
in his advanced class plus programming
styles of idioms book in 1992
based on this ghost paper she did not
vainly name it after herself but
um cope extracted that observation
which is why it gets associated in part
with objects
but we can actually do that here so i'm
going to add a new mixer
a non-duplicate top if you mix this in
with
a stack what it means is that when you
try and push onto the top
something that is already there then
it's going to ignore it so now i've
already got that at the top
okay so this is an interesting idea
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
write a test
okay i've got a set of tests here an ad
hoc testing framework
i've got a test here that says a
non-empty stack becomes deeper by
retaining a pushed item as its top
and then i've got the test body i've got
a new stack i push
ndc i push tech 10 i push tech down the
stack depth is three
and the top is tactile now just as a
clarification if you're not used to
javascript in javascript if you want
something to be really equal to
something
you just hold down your finger down on
the equals key key the more equal you
want it to be the more
equals equals equals you need but this
is like really equal three because it's
like yeah i mean
um so that seems to be the invariant
okay when i do this i compose i have my
conventional stack that has clearing
operations and things like that
then the test passes when i also mix in
a non-duplicate top
the test fails because we tried to push
tech town onto it twice
and it ignored the second one because
it's a non-duplicate top therefore
depth is two rather than three and the
test fails that's the key idea
lsp is actually a testable proposition
we are saying
that if i have something that says it's
the same type then it should pass the
same tests if it conforms to that
if it does not then it's not the same
type or our tests have made too much of
an implementation assumption
so this is actually a testable concept
but there's another idea here
um barbara liskoff wasn't really talking
about objects and classes the way we
understand them she was actually talking
about abstract data types she was
talking
about the substitutability she wasn't
talking about plug-in frameworks she was
talking about the idea
that if i have a program that is linked
with respect to
one implementation of type if i
substitute
an alternative implementation then that
program should have the same behavior
identically and she says the behavior of
p the program is unchanged when i want
to substitute for r2 that basically
means if you say
i'm going to have the same behavior but
add logging then you broke an lsp
because
the program no longer has the same
behavior it now does logging as well
so it's a this is so the strict
list of substitution really is quite
strict it really is about the data types
um and the uh privacy of that but we do
nonetheless have a a general principle
we can learn from it
even if we're not going to be so strict
and it was captured
back in the early 90s in the gang of
four books programmed to an interface
not an implementation
now that doesn't mean use the interface
construct um
in the programming language that you're
working in
well that's good um what it means is if
there's something that has a public
aspect and a non-public aspect
you depend on that and you organize your
code accordingly
um it's really about the shape of the
thing and that if we look at this from a
typescript point of view
i can characterize um i can say
this is what you can depend on interface
stack
if you have a thing and it claims to be
a stack then it should support depth
that returns a number
top can return anything pop doesn't
return anything
and a push takes anything and returns
void and i can take that previous
javascript
and actually make that claim that's why
this is interesting is because this
doesn't use the conventional
class construct of javascript but it
still satisfies the types
and that causes us to revisit the kind
of the big three
of object orientation the way that many
people have been taught them
particularly if they come through the
kind of c-plus plus java c-sharp
root is the big three encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism
what we actually learn and particularly
if you work with dynamic languages is
actually inheritance really isn't that
interesting
the big deal is polymorphism in
languages that have a static type system
inheritance is its main use of
inheritance it's for type conformance
it's not at all it's not that
important you use inheritance to get
polymorphism if i can get polymorphism
another way i will get it another way as
well
so in other words poly inheritance in a
statically typed language is an
enabler for polymorphism therefore it's
subordinate to it the real
criteria here is the polymorphism idea
and that's important when we look back
at this i can equally well
have a piece of code that expects stack
and have a completely different
implementation
written using the conventional class
construct that we find in typescript
and it will still satisfy it it is to do
with conformance to an interface whether
we have a derivation from it or not
is is a question of type system but it
is not fundamental to the paradigm
people have been mistaking their type
system for the paradigm i get this a lot
with um
when people sort of say they say
functional programming what a lot of
people who talk about
functional programming you actually mean
is henley mill the type system
um which excludes a number of functional
languages such as clojure
which doesn't have such a type system
often people are focusing on that one
thing and they take it to be the whole
and we see that this has been happening
all through history this is often how we
approach
paradise when we're new to them um
so and if we actually think about it
well clearly
what we've really got there is
encapsulation is the strongest point um
when we
the encapsulation is is the dominant
aspect followed by polymorphism
inheritance is less interesting or
important
because when we think about it the idea
of programming to an interface
why am i programmed to interface because
i'm hiding the implementation
so in other words it turns out class
hierarchies when constructed in a
list of style class hierarchies are an
example of encapsulation because you no
longer depend on
the implementation detail the concrete
class that's irrelevant
well isn't that encapsulation well yes
if you like it's a
it's a it's a dynamic extension of the
concept of encapsulation and good class
hierarchy using encapsulation
my favorite observation